whether it's a devilish new characters
cryptic ancests ancient prophecies or
giant worms the trailer for Doom part 2
is full of details that you might have
missed
it can be argued that the parent-child
relationship between lady Jessica and
Paul and maybe one of the most dynamic
in science fiction Dune author Frank
Herbert's characterization of Lady
Jessica is nuanced with her motives to
conceive Paul being her desperate love
of Duke Leto our treaties and her
personal desire to bring about the
quizat's hard Iraq the universe is super
being but as close as she and Paul are
in the first film the cracks begin to
show when Paul realizes how his Venice
lineage has affected him he still has a
long way to go before achieving his
Destiny but the closer he gets the more
it pushes him away from those who can
understand him though Paul seems to
believe that he must cling to his
father's principles he's already
slipping his Visions have shown him that
he will start an Intergalactic holy war
and with juletto not believing in
Revenge it's fair to say he wouldn't
approve of the genocide that Paul is
seemingly destined to cause this brings
Paul in a turmoil as he doesn't want to
be capable of these unspeakable acts but
Jessica continues to push him all while
he starts pulling away from her
influence we we gave them something to
hope for in the Doom bar 2 trailer we
see Lady Jessica gasping for air and
opening her eyes now the vibrant blue of
the fremant this color change usually
indicates prolonged exposure to spice an
addictive psychoactive substance found
only on the planet Iraqis considered the
most valuable substance in the universe
however the blood-crusting Jessica's
nose hints at a very specific source for
her blue eyes it's likely that this
scene is part of a spice Agony a ritual
in which members of the Benny Jesuit
voluntarily ingest a poison known as The
Water of Life liquid harvested from Sun
worms that die from drowning although
the Water of Life is fatal even in small
quantities high-ranking members of The
Sisterhood are able to transform the
substance into a benign liquid with
their mental Powers this incredibly
painful transformation unlocks a new
level of power within those who survive
transforming them into a reverend mother
there's even a possible glimpse of the
Water of Life a few seconds earlier in
the trailer pulled in a glass vial by a
cloaked figure Jessica
probably you play a major part in a
story throughout Dune part 2. and this
is most likely our first glimpse
princess Ireland is the eldest daughter
of the emperor of the known universe but
more importantly anyone familiar with
the Dune Saga will also be familiar with
Ireland's work as a historian of Herbert
beginning a significant number of
chapters with an epigraph from Ireland's
professional writings typically the
passage will frame a notable historical
events as it officially happened and
then the subsequent chapter will depict
that same event as it actually happened
in this way irolam remains a consistent
prevalent force in Dune without really
being present for all of the events of
the story not even physically appearing
in the first book until the end while
the Warner Brothers film May resist by
having Florence Pugh's princess making
her debut in Dune part 2. it also seems
that her role has been expanded upon the
era line in the first book did as she
was told and nothing more a passive
participant in her own life though what
she does later in this series is another
story entirely however the movie version
of Ireland seems to be actively asking
questions and seeking answers we can
guess the director didn't even planning
to tie he will learn more closely into
the main plot but or he might be setting
her up for future story arcs either way
it's safe to say that no one in their
right mind would cast Pew in this part
and not let her explore the space the
longest section of the Doom part 2
trailer teasers pulls first ride on a
sandworm he plays with a thumper in the
sand and readies for the massive
creature's arrival over the Montage we
can hear Zendaya's shiny have you ever
had a dream about your first ride this
question is likely more somber than it
initially seems in the novel by the time
Paul experiences his first sandworm ride
he's had many visions of the future and
they're not all hopeful in this scene
Shani is asking if he's foresino his
first ride will go and whether or not he
will survive Paul is a bit nervous to
ride the worm and he knows that he's
much older than most frame men when they
do so for the first time also the
continued trailer dialogue by Javier
badam Stilger advising Paul how to ride
shy halud is also pulled nearly word for
word out of the book
the Doom part 2 trailer shows us fade
ralpha harkinen played by Austin Butler
in all his bold treacherous Glory the
grave foil to pull the tradies and the
do novel fate is a nephew and intended
successor of Baron Vladimir harkinen
played on screen in Dune par 1 by
Stellan Skarsgard fade beds the same
drab reptilian look as a rest of his
vicious family with most of his moments
in the trailer shot in complete black
and white we see him participating in
the gladiatorial Arenas on gaydy Prime
the harken and Homeworld glimpsed
briefly in the first film we also see an
interaction with the Benny Jesuit lady
Margot fenring played by Leia sedu
finally we see what appears to be a shot
of fade facing off against poor with
Paul uttering the famous framing
challenge with a knife chip and shatter
we won't spoil it here but if you've
already read the book you know exactly
what this moment leads to the trailer
gives the audience members their very
first Glimpse at lady Margot though she
becomes a major character later in the
Dune book series it seems her part in
villanov's film may have been expanded
from her original role in the first
novel Margot is a member of the Benny
jesaret the powerful matriarchal order
who are partially responsible for the
destruction of House of Trades and
arakis they've spent centuries
orchestrating a selective breeding
program to cross Bloodlines of the
universe's Noble houses and hope to mate
Margot with fade ralpha harkinen this
will give the secret organization a leg
up as they'll have a member of House
harken and fully in their control
doubling the amount of power in their
possession book fans know that margot's
fate and pulls are closely intertwined
and that ultimately Paul's rise will
precipitate Margo's four but of course
this adaptation of Dune might switch
things around a bit for now it's clear
that Margot is here to stay
has been a shadow on House of tradies
from the opening moments of Dune part 1
but if you thought that Baron was bad
just wait for fade Villeneuve told
Vanity Fair Austin Butler brought to the
screen something that will be a cross
between a psychotic sociopath serial
killer and Mick Jagger this features
briefly in the trailer as fade doors in
an arena observed by Lady Margot as
we've said the connection between the
noble psychopath and the Benny Jesuit is
significant established in the first
film that Benny Jesuit our intent on
bringing about the quizart's hard Iraq
through centuries of meticulous breeding
you were told to Bear only daughters but
you and your pride thought you could
produce the quizzes hi Jessica giving
birth to a girl as was originally
planned the child would have eventually
wed fade in a political marriage with
their offspring likely being the
quizard's heart Iraq now Paul is rising
as a messiah of Iraqis cutting out the
hearkenings completely but the Benny
Jesuit don't appear to be giving up on
the hearkenings quite yet
the planet of Iraqis is foreboding and
hostile even for those who possess a
technology to travel Among the Stars a
desert Planet requires specialized
skills and knowledge for someone to be
able to survive although the planetary
colonists have ruling Noble houses
struggle to cultivate spice the fremen
Iraqis indigenous population are well
adopted utilizing several novel
technologies that allow their people to
flourish thank you for the still suits
they are fremin men
the best among the most notable items
are maker hooks featured prominently
throughout the Dune part 2 trailer these
hooks allow the fremin to mount and
steer the Giant sunworms and even though
Paul is told not to show off during his
first right attempt he's clearly quite
good at it maker hooks are important
within frame and culture because writing
a sound worm is a rite of passage into
adulthood forever able to use maker hugs
to steer a sandworm by cooking into gaps
in the sand worms plating forcing the
creatures to instinctively move in the
opposite direction even though it looks
like water's having fun in the Dune part
2 trailer this action means much more
than possessing a skill in the eyes of
the fremen Doom part 2 will feature many
characters on the hunt for Paul the
tradies as Princess Ireland's voice over
questions his face after the hearkening
attack we get a glimpse of Josh Brolin's
Gurney harlech looking through a pair of
binoculars the editors have snuck in
some clever imagery here since much of
Gurney's story in the sequel will
revolve around finding Paul and getting
revenge on someone he thought he could
trust even before the hearkening attack
Duke Leto knew there was a traitor
embedded in House of tradies in the
novel he even momentarily believed
Jessica could be the culprit given her
status as a Benny jesuret and Gurney is
likewise suspicious although audiences
know Chang Chen's doctor UA was the
traitor Gurney hasn't learned that
information and has continued to believe
that lady Jessica aided the harkinance
when we pick up with him in Dune part 2
he's one of the few survivors of the
original attack searching a raucus for
Paul and bowing revenge on Jessica while
Gurney didn't have much to do in Dune
part 1 he still plays a significant role
as one of Bull's major allies once the
daughter Paul's potential opens it
cannot be closed his Visions start
simply at first with nightly dreams of
chani whom he has yet to meet but more
and more his mind opens thanks to the
spice and soon he knows many things that
he wishes he didn't as his Destiny is
revealed so is his mother's fate before
Jessica even confirms that she's
pregnant in Dune part 1 Paul tells her
of the baby she will have in his mind he
sees Jessica's blue within blue eyes and
her future facial tattoos though we
can't definitively say what the tattoos
mean we can give a pretty accurate guess
Jessica has built a life around the
Benny Jesuit and fulfilling the prophecy
of the quizards had Iraq a mind
powerful enough
Bridge space and time we will never told
Vanity Fair Lady Jessica is one of the
masterminds of Dune she's trying to play
her own agenda the meaning of that look
would be unveiled in part two it seems
just as Paul comes to terms with his
place in the universe so too does
Jessica
are many mysterious forces in play
throughout the Galaxy depicted in Dune
Paul is the product of a long line of
genetic manipulation for the express
purpose of creating a superhuman capable
of leading Humanity into a universal
Golden Age this Benny jesura breeding
program cultivates each successive
generation to possess greater Acumen
with their mental Powers one of the most
notable Powers is known as The Voice
this skill is prominently seen and heard
in Dune part 1 when Jessica and Paul
escaped their assassination attempt to
turn the hearken and coup
we know how bad
the power essentially allows us
practitioners to mentally dominate most
individuals in the final moments of the
Doom part 2 trailer Paul is addressing
an assembly of fremin although the music
swells one can hear some hints of the
voices distinct auditory cue maybe
implying that Paul uses a voice to Rally
the fremant to his cause
[Music]